STEVE: Look at this.
Ooh.
STEVE: My grandfather
made that for my mother
to ride on the boardwalk
in Ocean City, Maryland.
So he made this?
Yeah.
MIKE (VOICEOVER): Bicycling
was a very social event
around the turn of the century.
There were a lot
of bicycling clubs.
There were a lot of
innovations in bicycles.
And a tandem back then
was the woman in front
and the man in the back.
And it's what they called
the "steer from the rear."
So the man was actually
steering the handlebars
for the woman in front.
They're beautiful bikes.
But the side-by-side
tandems are very rare.
There was a company called
Wolfe American around the turn
of the century that
made a social tandem,
they call these, where you
can sit next to each other.
I want to say that this was
probably made in the '30s.
And he probably patterned it
after one of those others.
MIKE: The Wolfe American
side-by-side tandem
that was made during
the turn of the century
is an expensive bike.
It's a very collectible bike.
This bike that I'm looking
at is not that bike.
So the fork looks like
it's off an English bike.
Well, I love how he
did the rear hub.
Look at that hub, Frank.
Maybe his grandfather did
this to promote the shop.
I started working
for a bike shop,
and I was basically in the
warehouse assembling bikes.
And then I finally
moved up to working
on the sales floor of the shop.
And then I owned my own
shop for a number of years.
Wow.
It was really pretty cool.
It was like too old bike
guys talking to each other.
I had my own shop.
MIKE: --Your own boss.
--for a while, too.
MIKE: Oh, you did?
I did.
I went to school at
UVA in Charlottesville.
And when I went down there,
there were no bicycle shops.
MIKE: You had a shop while
you were going to school?
STEVE: I did.
MIKE: Wow.
STEVE: I went part
time, which is why it
took me 10 years to graduate.
[laughs]
I can talk about collecting
bikes to a number of people.
But it's not often
I run into somebody
that I can talk to
about the bicycle
business, the ins and outs.
That was exciting to me.
So what are you going to do
with this or the girls' bike?
STEVE: We have to get
rid of what's here.
MIKE: Mm-hm.
STEVE: I don't
have space for it.
I'm starting to see more
and more girl collectors.
- Really?
- When I started dat--
- Of bikes?
- Yeah.
When I started buying old
bikes 25, 30 years ago, man,
there was hardly
any girl collectors.
It's a girls bike.
I don't really buy girls
bikes, but it's prewar.
This is the best
part of the bike.
It has a very rare
fender ornament.
And the fact that it's got
original paint is great too.
And then I noticed
underneath the shelving,
there is a road racing bike.
I'm like, this is
going to be good.
[grunts] Let me see here.
Oh, yeah!
It's Raleigh International.
That's my old bike.
MIKE: That's your bike?
So you were riding in style.
This was the type of bike that
I drooled over when I was a kid.
That's a tall bike.
STEVE: Yeah, it's
a 23-inch frame.
MIKE (VOICEOVER):
Built of Reynolds
531 double-butted tubing.
The butted tubes, you know
what that means, Frank?
Butted tubes, so
they go together?
No, the tube is actually
twice as thick here,
and it's drawn thinner.
FRANK: OK.
So it reduces the weight.
It's got camp
Ignoble parts on.
Camp Ignoble Italian components
were the top of the line.
There was nothing
that touched them.
Oh, it doesn't have the
Alfredo Binda straps.
Uh, no.
Yeah.
[laughter]
STEVE: But you have
to understand--
Wow, look at this thing.
In 1979, when the movie
"Breaking Away" came out,
it was a game
changer in my life.
There was a young
guy in that movie
that was completely engulfed
in the European cycling world.
You know, his heroes
were Eddy Merckx, Bernard
Hinault. I mean, when
I was 14 years old,
I knew who those guys were.
I was riding around on
European racing bikes,
and not a lot of
people understood that.
So what year do you this is?
STEVE: Probably '68
or '69, I'd say.
Yeah, because it's got
the center pole brakes.
Yeah.
Doesn't have the
caliper brakes on it.
Finding this Raleigh
International just
brings so much of
my childhood back.
Now, these bikes, they're
getting collectible.
They were expensive back
then, and they're still
expensive to this day, because
the guys that were riding them
they want to ride them again.
Is this something you'd sell?
STEVE: I don't ride no mountain
bike these days, so yeah.
How about 300 on this?
Um, the women's bike,
this, like, two bills.
I mean, I-- this stuff
right here, it's easy for me
to gauge.
But when you start
talking about the tandem--
Right.
I have no idea about that.
MIKE: That's the thing
that probably has a lot
of sentimental value to it.
STEVE (VOICEOVER):
When Mike first
looked at that
side-by-side tandem,
my mother used to
ride that bike.
So I needed to think about it.
I just-- it was tough.
300 on the Raleigh
International and 200
on the Dayton.
- Good.
MIKE: Can you do that?
STEVE: Works for me, yeah.
- All right.
- Thank you.
MIKE (VOICEOVER): We
decided to put the tandem
on the back burner for now.
But at least I was
able to cut a deal
on the Raleigh International
and the Dayton girls' bike.
I mean, he was
passing the torch.
This was his bike.
And I think one of
the reasons he sold me
the bike is because I understood
the significance of it,
because no way he's
going to sell it
to somebody that didn't get it.
So it was like
the perfect storm.